lassen sie uns abschließend herr sparen
über ihr fach thema noch einmal sprechen
über natürlich die korona krise jetzt
drohte uns 3g in zügen und bahnen also
nur noch bahn fahren wenn man geimpft
getestet oder genesen ist ist offenbar
abgeräumt und das ist ihnen zu verdanken
es gibt eine prüfbitte gab es wir haben
geprüft vor allem das
verkehrsministerium federführend
offenkundig ja auch für bahnfahrten und
da gibt es in drei themen hat es eine
rechtsgrundlage sozusagen die rechtliche
betrachtungsweise ist es praktikabel ist
es überhaupt umsetzbar da muss man
gesehen wir haben anderes system als als
frankreich also in frankreich werden sie
kommen sie gar nicht in den bahnhof rein
zumindest in schnellzügen wenn sie nicht
schon dinge vorweisen und darlegen bei
uns sind bahnhöfe einfach öffentlicher
raum und
ganz anders zugänglich also im
kanzleramt wissen gehört habe und mir
wissen können es ist praktikabel und die
dritte frage ist ist es infektiologie in
dieser pandemie jetzt auch unbedingt
erforderlich dann in der in der abwägung
und da haben wir einfach noch mal
geschaut wie sind die erfahrungen was
ausbruchsgeschehen angeht und
zusammengefasst kommen wir eben aus den
fachressorts die sich mit diesen drei
fragen beschäftigt haben zu dem von
ihnen beschriebenen jahres abgeräumt das
ding ist tot 3g in zügen kommt nicht ich
sehe es nicht kommen jetzt stehen wir
also aber nicht heißt dass wir nicht
trotzdem aufeinander aufpassen sollten
in den zügen ist ja klar dass nelly sind
warum ist das auch auch einfach möglich
weil schutzmasken wichtig sind das macht
ihr schutzmasken in den zügen umso
wichtiger es gibt ja einige die wollen
überall die masken fallen lassen sie
nicht nicht in dem bereich wo ich möchte
jetzt muss man sich entscheiden drei hat
er schon mal auch in gesprächen hatte
hier mal ein mal im juni glaube ich oder
ende mai gesagt 'ja ja wenn jeder die
möglichkeit hatte sich impfen zu lassen
das haben wir längst hat die
bundesregierung festgestellt dann kann
auch das kommt auch der moment was sich
aber verändert hat zum beispiel ist
dieser starke anteil delta und das was
wir auch anschließend gesehen haben wie
viel ansteckender diese variante ist und
die zahl der ungeimpften ist verbunden
mit delta einfach noch so groß dass eine
tatsächliche starke belastung des
gesundheitswesens sehr wahrscheinlich
ist wir haben die pandemie der
ungeimpften jeder der nicht geimpft ist
wenn die zahlen jetzt weiter steigen
wird sich mit nahezu hundertprozentiger
sicherheit ohne schutz in herbst und
winter dann anstecken und das ist schon
noch eine andere lage als wir sie noch
vom halben jahr hatten mit einer anderen
variante jetzt steigen die zahlen
tatsächlich weiter wir werden womöglich
im laufe dieser woche diese magische 100
wieder erreichen beim incidents wert auf
denen wir ja nicht mehr so genau schauen
wollen oder nicht mehr nur
ausschließlich auf diesen wert was
passiert eigentlich wenn wir im laufe
dieser woche diesen wert erreichen von
der 100 dann ist das erst mal für sich
genommen auch keine gute entwicklung
weil es einfach zeigt dass dieses virus
sich immer weiter immer schneller
ausbreite das alles passiert erstmal
wegen der 100 für sich genommen und gar
nichts außer dass ich einfach nur die
bürgerinnen und bürger bitte miteinander
zu sehen wir wo es ist gerade unterwegs
aufeinander aufpassen losgeht im alltag
aber wir haben ja im miteinander vor
allem ein hauptkriterium seit beginn der
pandemie übrigens unser haupt grund auch
warum wir die maßnahmen ergriffen haben
wir sie ergriffen haben war ja die
funktionsfähigkeit des gesundheitswesens
dass wir patientinnen und patienten auch
tatsächlich klar derzeit behandeln
können und das ist jetzt eben ein stück
ist es nicht völlig losgelöst natürlich
wenn die zahlen immer weiter steigen
wird auch voller in den kliniken aber es
ist jetzt weiter entkoppelt als es vor
dem impfen war der 100 passiert erstmal
nichts mehr was es dann die neue grenze
also sozusagen für sie zumindest im kopf
die notbremse wir haben ja einen
vorschlag gemacht wurde
infektionsschutzgesetz dass wir jetzt
die sogenannte hospitalisierung residenz
nehmen heißt also wie fico will 19
patienten wurden in den letzten sieben
tagen neu aufgenommen in den kliniken
und das macht schon sinn dass auch
regional unterschiedlich zu betrachten
weil natürlich die versorgungsdichte die
versorgungssituation auch regional
unterschiedlich ist wenn sie mich fragen
was ist denn so ein wert der zumindest
mal eine idee davon gibt die sehr starke
belastung die wir gesehen haben im
dezember januar in der zweiten dritten
welle war zum beispiel mit die stärkste
belastung 15 19 patienten neu
aufgenommen in den letzten sieben tagen
pro 100000 einwohner hat das war eine
situation regional da ist das
gesundheitswesen schon sehr
unter unter starker belastung ans limit
angekommen
und das ist eine größenordnung die ich
jedenfalls nicht wieder erreichen will